were you ever like actually in a real
office that kind of job I was in a
pretend office for nine years yes you
were we know this yes
the best what does like Dwight from the
office think about this story would
Dwight want to be in the office or at
home do I it would have been so much fun
to film the office during the pandemic
we'd have Pandemic episodes that would
be amazing but I would have loved to
have seen that because it's like
reflective of what the entire world went
through yeah and you know the office
writers were so great they would have
been able to spin that in some beautiful
ways but I think it would be you know he
gets the call from corporate to get
everyone back in the office and everyone
is resistant so one at a time Dwight has
to kidnap every Office cast member and
bring them into Dunder Mifflin in some
kind of obscure and somewhat
inappropriate way where is this show
right now Greenland in my life
totally